you heard about what happened to
superman yesterday yes i did
yes
uh superman's son is uh
it's bisexual yeah yeah i mean good good
for him i didn't see him and and and
i'm more concerned with dc making social
media yesterday yeah i decided this
morning actually what do you guys what
do you think about it
david let me ask superman's dc comics
coming out
the next superman's son is a bisexual
superman that's coming up soon
he's bisexual like in the comic world
like a bisexual socialist no no a real
superman son yeah in the comic world
i don't know like if you're talking
about dean kane or whoever that's no no
no no that's the story like the comic
story that they see universe superman's
son is by good for him
what do you think about that
i think it's lazy it doesn't bother me
that he's bisexual it doesn't bother me
that bothers me socialist but i mean it
doesn't bother me he's bisexual
i don't know
i know people are bisexual i know people
that are gay if they feel somehow
edified by this good for them i just
think it's lazy why not make your own
superhero make your own story the
constant retconing of these you know
cultural icons and listen
they are doing it on purpose so when
they act like how are you getting mad
because you wanted people to get mad
superman's a jesus allegory superman was
a way to sell jesus to a new sense of
kid he's he's jesus if you look at the
uh if you look at zack snyder's um
uh bat at superman right i mean he
literally has him being resurrected with
his feet crossed in his arms it it's a
jesus allegory it's the most obvious
jesus already since the matrix right so
i mean the fact that they know this and
then they went out of their way in the
press conference the way they were like
we just
we knew having another white male
straight white male savior uh would have
been a missed opportunity and it's like
okay so then you did it on purpose like
but he's not gay he's bisexual
apparently no no so the picture why
don't you pull it up to see the picture
i mean
his job is how does he not already know
you tell kai to taipei he types me just
sleeping over there
that's a great post pbd podcast
[Music]
i got to see this picture because i i
got to go to images there it is right
there this freaking guy there it is okay
let me say something
i i know women
that are bisexual meaning they're into
dudes they're the chicks
i don't know any dudes that are bisexual
if you're asking some d you're gay
that's it
there's no
there's no middle ground well you know i
from time to time i'll jerk a guy off
but
no i think i'm gonna go out no it's it's
done i'm sorry you do that no i'm in the
chicks that's it oh i thought you said
from time to time
i'm just i'm i'm i'm putting my foot if
you're gay god bless you all good i've
got gay friends
he wants it from
11 years from now 11 years again i know
a lot of gay people they're cool
people miami beach south beach they're
everywhere i'm friends with them some of
my good friends are gay see them out all
the time say what's up yeah i'm with
none of them
none of them are going home with girls
i'm with you on this girard
why be so lazy you could create a whole
new
series of different specifically to piss
people off they're doing it to piss
people off so i mean that's i i go from
not being pissed off to just do i care
yeah dc comics who's the founder of dc
comics no i don't know who's who
is this a stanley project or no it's not
stanley
marvel so who's uh who's the dc comics
frank miller is the big is the video
uh go to dc comics right there wikipedia
go to the bottom yeah just type on
let's see who it is so malcolm wheeler
i'm sure so 87 years ago founder by the
city of national general malcolm wheeler
wheeler
the black superman thing it's like a
little
organization so if i was a black
superman you know i'm just playing you
kind of are you as close to superman as
it gets thank you yeah dude he's can't
fly yet huh just can't fly yet a little
higher a little x-ray vision have you
tried you got to make the leap bro
like the matrix bro you got to make the
leap
i don't know man it doesn't just feel
lazy isn't it i just feel like i'm
saying it does feel that yeah yeah
trying too hard to sell you something
something like it's like i don't know we
get to sell the gay people
i think the guy that we had on from
facebook who is part of the lgbtq
community
he himself said that uh on facebook
they're trying really hard
to influence young kids to be part of
the community so
you know if that is the strategy let's
just say that's the strategy and where
the marketing from they hired great
strategy good for you he didn't like
that right he did not like that even
though he's part he is himself a part of
it he doesn't like the fact that you're
trying to manipulate kids yeah and so
gatsa the godfather you know when he and
i we're we got to get them on here we
got to figure out a day to get them out
of the parasitic mine yes
when i had them on and we were talking
about the whole lgbt test do you think
that tv shows and everything is
influencing kids to become
a part of the community says not at all
i said let's look at some stats so we
went to the stats last 30 40 years and
you can tell 34 20 years ago was one
percent lgbt today's five percent that
was literally what i wanted to find out
you're saying five percent in the last
20 years yeah in the last 20 years it's
increased from 1 to 5 it falls under the
lgbtq by the way
they've added new letters
yeah they've got to stop at p though i
think we can all agree on that b l b g b
t b whatever you want i think there was
like the p is the pie in there at one
point yeah i'm not i'm not even like
like guy pull up lgbt like there's
three new letters that i didn't know
there's a point of the game abcd is 26
letters yeah what else
i think pb
p
q i lgbtqia plus in there there it is
you're right you're right you're right
let's begin by say transgender uh q i a
what does lg yeah click on that
uh vicente transgender don't turn it
down
i'm the only one right there the second
one click on the second one no nobody
else says cat ears
that's click on that one uh okay lesbian
gay bisexual transgender questioning
queer intersex pansexual
all right this is too much i'm confused
and dude respect to all you guys but
like if i'm a gay person
now i got to be
in between everything and i'm telling
you right now didn't dave should do a
joke about this you want to be with a
consenting adult
with the children is where that [ __ ] is
a hard line yes where hard where kevin
spacey came out and they were like hey
man are you with a 15 year old dude he's
like you know what you're right i
decide to live my life outwardly as a
gay man and the whole world was like
cool cool but what about the 15 yeah
exactly like that's that's all we're
talking about here man what about the
head
drag stuff at night no you know with the
kids no no no it's hard no live your
life listen
age you know age doesn't matter
yeah it does it let's just it does
i mean come on man you look whatever you
do with a consenting adult god bless so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]